[Music]
if you're ever walking down the street
and come across an oddly stretched out
image like this you'll have an
opportunity to see something remarkable
but only if you stand in exactly the
right spot that happens because these
works employ a technique called an
amorphous an amorphous as' is a special
case of perspective art where artists
represent realistic three-dimensional
views on two-dimensional surfaces though
it's common today this kind of
perspective drawing has only been around
since the Italian Renaissance ancient
art often showed all figures on the same
plane varying in size by symbolic
importance classical Greek and Roman
artists realize they could make objects
seem further by drawing them smaller but
many early attempts at perspective were
inconsistent or incorrect
in 15th century Florence artists realize
the illusion of perspective could be
achieved with higher degrees of
sophistication by applying mathematical
principles in 1485 Leonardo da Vinci
manipulated the mathematics to create
the first known anamorphic drawing
a number of other artists later picked
up the technique including Hans Holbein
in the ambassador's
this painting features a distorted shape
that forms into a skull as the viewer
approaches from the side in order to
understand how artists achieve that
effect we first have to understand how
prospective drawings work in general
imagine looking out a window light
bounces off objects and into your eye
intersecting the window along the way
now imagine you could paint the image
you see directly onto the window while
standing still and keeping only one eye
open the result would be nearly
indistinguishable from the actual view
with your brain adding depth to the 2d
picture but only from that one spot
standing even just a bit off to the side
would make the drawing lose its 3d
effect
artists understand that a prospective
drawing is just a projection onto a 2d
plane this allows them to use math to
come up with basic rules of perspective
that allow them to draw without a window
one is that parallel lines like these
can only be drawn as parallel if they're
parallel to the plane of the canvas
otherwise they need to be drawn
converging to a common point known as
the vanishing point
so that's a standard perspective drawing
with an anamorphic drawing like The
Ambassadors
directly facing the canvas makes the
image look stretched and distorted but
put your eye in exactly the right spot
way off to the side and the skull
materializes going back to the window
analogy it's as if the artist painted
onto a window positioned at an angle
instead of straight on so that's not how
Renaissance artists actually created
anamorphic drawings typically they draw
a normal image onto one surface then use
a light a grid or even strings to
project it onto a canvas at an angle
now let's say you want to make an
anamorphic sidewalk drawing in this case
you want to create the illusion that a
3d image has been added seamlessly into
an existing scene you can first put a
window in front of the sidewalk and draw
what you want to add onto the window it
should be in the same perspective as the
rest of the scene which might require
the use of those basic rules of
perspective once the drawing is complete
you can use a projector placed where
your eye was to project your drawing
down onto the sidewalk then chalk over
it the sidewalk drawing and the drawing
on the window will be nearly
indistinguishable from that point of
view so viewers brains will again be
tricked into believing that the drawing
on the ground is three-dimensional and
you don't have to project onto a flat
surface to create this illusion you can
project onto multiple surfaces or
assemble a jumble of objects that from
the right point of view appears to be
something else entirely
all over the planet you can find solid
surfaces giving way to strange wonderful
or terrifying visions
from your sidewalk to your computer
screen these are just some of the ways
that math and perspective can open up
whole new worlds
[Music]
you